well kill the company is all about
getting rid of things that don't work to
make space for things that do work and
how this all happened was you know I
have a group of trainers that are
located around the world and we teach
people about innovation and change and
something very interesting was happening
that the leaders that were bringing us
in to actually teach change were the
very ones that were holding us back from
doing it and we wanted to know why why
is this happening and we did a lot of
research over the years and worked with
thousands of clients and what we found
was that people are approaching change
all wrong and what we found was this the
very things that most companies put in
place to help us better innovate or
embrace change
so meetings reports policies procedures
while important they can't be the only
thing that you do and unfortunately
people were putting so many of those
things in place they were putting a
chokehold on change and innovation so
our conjecture around kill the company
is what you need to do first before you
innovate is get rid of the things that
aren't working Challenge the way things
have been done before so you can make
space for things to work better so the
idea for Kilda company came about from a
very I'll say painful experience and
here's what happened we were brought
down to visit a company a large
manufacturing company in North Carolina
they were doing an executive off-site
and they're about 50 of their senior
leaders there and they asked us to do
some visioning exercises etc and myself
and a few other trainers were leading
this workshop and after about an hour
into the workshop I'll tell you it was
very obvious to us we were doing
exercises like envision the future and
from impossible to possible and we
noticed the people just weren't buying
it and we took a break and I'll tell you
it was one of those things where you
just didn't want to come back into the
room but you had to and I pulled one of
the executives aside and I said what's
going on you know because they brought
us down here to talk about futuring and
change and it was it was a very seminal
moment the executive said you know ELISA
it's not that we don't want change to
happen it's that we no longer believe we
can affect it and I thought you know
what does that say if senior leaders
feel that way how does the rest of the
organization feel so you know the idea
for kill the company came out of one of
those snap moments we went back into the
room and I had everybody throw out their
agendas and this was one of those
make-it-or-break-it moments right and I
said everybody rearrange into your table
groups by function or business unit
right so you had legal or marketing or
rocketry whatever it was and I asked
everybody to pretend that they were
their number one competitor so whatever
group they were in pretend they were
their number one competitor and I said
over the next 30 minutes your job is to
put your company out of business and it
was like we gave them this out of
company experience right where they were
forced to attack the things that were
wrong
rather than being politically correct
and what was really interesting about it
was they came up with ideas to kill
their company and then after 30 minutes
they turned those ideas back on to their
own competitors so they were they were
killing meetings they were killing rules
it was really a cathartic exercise that
was a really different way to approach
strategic planning because how we most
of us approach strategic planning is how
to come up with more things for the next
year and rarely do we start with getting
rid of the things that don't work first
and that's how kill the company can be
really productive
you